DEMOCRATS TO DO THE RIGHT THING?
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT IF YOU THINK THE REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING DO IT, I THINK YOU ARE
VERY MISTAKEN.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SEE PRESIDENT
BIDEN, SENATOR, RUN FOR A SECOND
TERM?
>> WELL, WHAT I WANT TO SEE
RIGHT NOW IS THAT THE CONGRESS
OF THE UNITED STATES WORKING
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN NEXT YEAR.
DEVELOP AN AGENDA THAT SAYS TO
WORKING FAMILIES AND THE ELDERLY
AND THE KIDS WE UNDERSTAND YOUR
PAIN AND THAT WE HAVE THE GUTS
TO TAKE ON THE BIG MONEY
INTERESTS AT A TIME WHEN WE HAVE
MORE INCOME AND WEALTH
INEQUALITY THAN ANY OTHER MAJOR
COUNTRY ON THE EARTH.
WOLF, YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY THIS
AGAIN.
I THINK RECENT EVENTS POINT THIS
OUT.
THIS COMPANY IS MOVING TOWARD AN
OLIGARCHIC FORM OF SOCIETY WHERE
YOU'VE GOT THREE PEOPLE ON TOP
WHO OWN MORE WEALTH THAN THE
BOTTOM HALF OF AMERICAN SOCIETY.
YOU'VE GOT THREE WALL STREET
FIRMS THAT HAVE CONTROL ASSETS
OF OVER $20 TRILLION.
THAT'S THE GDP OF THE UNITED
STATES.
UNBELIEVABLE WEALTH AND POWER AT
THE TOP WHILE THE MIDDLE CLASS
IS IN DECLINE AND LOWER INCOME
PEOPLE ARE REALLY SUFFERING.
WE NEED TO WORK RIGHT NOW, NEXT
YEAR WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN ON IT
TO ADDRESS -- ON AN AGENDA THAT
ADDRESSES THOSE ISSUES.
>> WELL, LET ME REPHRASE THE
QUESTION.
DO YOU WANT TO SEE HIM RUN FOR
REELECTION?
>> LOOK, RIGHT NOW MY CONCERN IS
ELECTING M